well I'm here in Osaka with mark and
with Rupa whom we met through the
internet because I discovered Rupa's
videos okay I was very impressed by his
enthusiasm thank you for the
professional quality of your videos
because you should say this because my
viewers say give me subtitles at work
Rupa does a first-class job of doing
that Thanks so I want to ask you will
put you're from Australia I'm from
Melbourne Australia okay one question I
always get how big a deal is XM so
people say should I learn Mexican
Spanish or European Spanish or
Australian English or what do you think
of this issue well that's a great
question and then I'll tell you what I
think okay so what I think is it might
be a bit tricky if for example you want
to go to Australia
and you have zero idea of the Australian
accent you might find yourself in you
know some difficult situations but if
you're especially a beginner or you're
just getting started and language and
you just want to have some basic
communications basic conversations make
some friends I think don't worry about
it too much thank you okay it will make
such a big deal
yeah about accents okay I mean you got
European Portuguese Brazilian Portuguese
when I studied Portuguese I did both
because I'm gonna meet some people who
speak Portuguese some who please speak
Brazilian Portuguese Spanish that the
vowels don't change like there's very
little difference okay and even I'm not
even conscious when I was beating with
you in English that in fact you're
speaking Australian yes because the
words are ninety nine point does say
absolutely so that's good people
shouldn't worry
and in fact
it's in their interest to be exposed to
a variety of accents and if at some
point you're gonna be working in Quebec
you're gonna be working in Australia
yeah then you might want to focus in on
that accent but as you said you know for
a good long while as you're getting used
yeah don't worry about it
can't even tell the difference even
though the same words the written is the
same and it takes a certain level of
sophistication actually to be able to
recognize similar in Japanese you know
you might meet someone from Kanto region
and someone from Kansai and then they
speak differently yeah but but a
beginner one oh yeah I started learning
it yeah I didn't worry about it at all
there are only when you get to that
advanced level right and he's not living
in Tokyo you start living in all second
you start to pick up little things next
question when you came to Japan I know
you studied some japanese in austria yes
that is always one level that you have
when you go well I just finished high
school and then I came here so I could
do a very basic conversation and nothing
you know like going to the doctor or
guys setting up a bank account so that
was hallo
friend no experience I could read and
write you know some of the basic
countries but then when I actually got
handed like you know something in
Japanese like a menu I couldn't read it
at all so then when you got here yes
what was your strategy first of all when
you got here where were you doing were
you working with
school and all the other alts assistant
language teacher at a at a middle school
alright so that was fun
okay so what was your strategy in terms
of approaching Japanese and getting your
Japanese level up well I'm pretty
outgoing guy I love meeting new people
so what I did was I went to a lot of
bars or izakayas right I just started
conversations with people right and just
with the little Japanese that I did have
you know I spoke pretty basically but
with that I could get a couple of
conversations going right no friends see
them again and again
and then I would go to a language school
every Sunday just to chew up some of the
grammars right yeah and and right now
you are at University yeah now I'm
studying how are your classes in
Japanese our name in Japanese in
Japanese so you have to do your reading
in Japanese yeah so you have to have
quite a few kanji to read yeah now now
I've set you know step of the kanji now
to what extent has going to university
here yeah what effect do you feel that
has on your ability to have
conversations with people in terms of
conversation I think not too much
because the Japanese I'm learning in
school is very formal right so for
example might be studying business
japanese which is all Cagle right so
we're learning you know King juggle song
Kegel 10 there you go what's the
differences between these but when I'm
just meeting someone you know for lunch
but we don't use that if I started to
use those as they'll think I'm you know
her being a little bit that's
interesting because my experience here
was yeah all of my interactions with
Japanese was business challenges okay I
didn't meet people in bars I mean yeah
my wife and two kids and you were
working and if everything was this was
business and even the conversations we
would have in the evening a lot like I
had a customer in Nagoya
we would like to talk philosophy yeah he
bought newsprint I worked for Canadian
Forest Products Company yeah and every
once a month I had to go to Nagoya sit
there in a Japanese significant red
restaurant with him and polish off a
bottle of whiskey and discuss philosophy
the moment you become absolutely
now you interact a lot with Japanese
people who are learning English yeah
what do you think are the major
difficulties like
you compare your efforts at learning
Japanese starting in Australia yeah and
then when you came here versus what you
see with Japanese people who are
learning English ones it's similar what
is different so so what's the
difficulties for Japanese people
learning English right I think with
Japan I noticed this when I was a middle
school teacher is that they're very shy
to speak it right so they tell a lot of
my students would write these beautiful
essays and have their grammar spot on
you know use some pretty advanced
vocabulary but then I went out ask him
in the hallway how's your day going
they'd go oh sorry you know they'll get
shot it shook up you know yeah so I
think you know just getting out of their
shell actually practicing English and
that way when you practice it more and
more you know that the words that you do
learn they get reinforced into your
memory right they're learning it but
they're not actually using it right they
they might use it once in an essay but
have to look it up in a dictionary right
but they're they're not using it again
and again with with their friends or
with their teachers no of course you're
here in Japan you have the opportunity
to use it again and again yeah when you
were in Australia you didn't have that
offer yeah so they're in that situation
they don't really have the chance to you
that's yeah so what can they do
I mean they can't obviously if you live
where the language is spoken and you
have a certain level of comprehension
then you can work on that too yeah raise
your level but someone who's the
Japanese learning English here you
learning Japanese in Australia yeah yeah
many people learn at home and they don't
have that opportunity what do they do
well I guess now you know with the
internet there's so many things to do
right yeah you know there's language
exchange websites so you know great you
know YouTube channels like yours okay
and all websites programs like that and
and then I guess you're speeding up
those habits right I like you said you
know listening listening to that music
or if you enjoy it or you know watching
that TV shows that you like again and
again and just kind of trying to immerse
yourself in the language
basically the same exact immerse
yourself so that those words yeah there
are in calabria context right after
whether they're whether yours being here
listening or watching TV and you you
recognize a word and you hear it see it
in multiple contexts and eventually you
don't know that word and eventually
you're actually able to use that word
right that's so I think we can maybe
finish off on this point that we have
become yet and that is that you are and
we are examples of language
entrepreneurs yeah
people who are taking language learning
out of the classroom into the incident
okay the world August fear yeah you know
YouTube is fear yeah and people who are
out there learning are then benefiting
from this understand we're all enjoying
doing it yeah and leg finders yeah
that's it we've really yes thank you
very much
[Music]